today we're gonna talk about vs code
tips and tricks my name is wade Anderson
and I work on the team as a program
manager just to be clear cuz last year I
was at build and I gave a similar talk
to this and when I started a whole bunch
of people got up and left and I figured
out it was because they thought it was
for visual studio tips and tricks' now
this is for Visual Studio code tips and
tricks so if you need to get up and
leave because if you thought it's for
visual studio that's okay I won't take
offense so I'm going to talk about some
of the most useful and underused
tips and tricks get give me an idea of
how many of you have heard of vs code
raise the pen okay a lot of you how many
use it daily okay so we got a fair
amount for those that are new I'm gonna
give you a brief introduction visual
studio code is part of the visual studio
family it's a lightweight code editor if
you've used notepad plus plus sublime
text Adam you can think that Visual
Studio code is similar there what we
what we tried to do what our vision with
the product was is to bring some of the
best from IDE s like Visual Studio and
Eclipse and IntelliJ and bring it to a
lightweight editor experience so that's
what we tried to do here with vs code
some unique characteristics of it is its
cross-platform so it'll run on Mac Linux
and Windows it's free and open source we
do a lot of our development in the open
and are really transparent about what
we're trying to do and try to involve
the community and where we're going with
this product this talk is going to be
short 20 minutes there's no way I'm
going to cover all of the cool things
you can do with vs code so there's this
this github repo it's really easy to
find just search vs code tips and tricks
and you'll find it and it has dozens and
dozens of different tips and tricks
things I'm not going to cover today I
tried to squash down the ten most
important tips and tricks so tip number
one is stay cutting-edge by using the
insiders
version of es code so if you look down
here I'm running this green one right
here Visual Studio code insiders right
next to it is Visual Studio code this is
the month-to-month release version vs
code insiders is cool because we use
this to develop the product and that
there's some cool stories of people
reporting a bug and then seeing it fixed
the next morning when they go in on
insider so we release the we build
insiders nightly so you're getting the
latest features and the latest bug fixes
really quickly and now the second one
which is really catered towards those
that are new or maybe you've just tried
vyas code recently in the last few
months if I go here to help and then
welcome if you've just recently
downloaded the product this will show up
for you automatically let me get the
right font here so everyone can see this
this welcome screen has a lot of the hey
this will get you up to speed quickly
built into it especially this Quick
Links section so I'm going to go briefly
through this you can see a quick
overview of the interface we don't have
a complex interface it's pretty simple
but this can teach you the vernacular we
use in other parts of the product to
make things make sense this color theme
an important part of vs code is you can
customize it to make it look however you
want there's these dozen or so built in
automatically so you can choose the
theme that that you prefer or you can go
here and install literally hundreds of
different color themes and there's a lot
of options there you know we feel as
developers we spend hours and hours
looking at our editors all day so we
wanted to give you the the most exposure
you could to find the right theme for
yourself
so that's color themes now this third
one which is which I'm a big fan of is
if you're coming from a different
product you can install we call it a key
map so it's a whole package of key
bindings and its really useful say
you've used vim sublime text Visual
Studio and you've memorized these key
bindings you've built up the sweat
equity this muscle memory
you can actually just go and here's the
visual studio one you can install it and
then you don't have to learn new key
bindings you can just use the key
bindings you used with Visual Studio so
it makes it really easy to switch from
product to product often that's what
people do they run BS code alongside
some other tool that they're using so
that's right here install keyboard
shortcuts find and run all commands this
one if there's two things I want you to
remember from this talk it's remember
this this is one of them if you go ctrl
shift P or command shift P on a Mac this
will open the find and run all commands
and the cool thing about this is every
command you can run in vs code is
available right here and you can just
quickly start typing to find oh you need
to find settings okay that's right here
it makes it really easy to navigate
around the tool and find things that are
useful keyboard shortcut reference you
can go download a PDF put it by your by
your computer configure settings I'll go
over a little bit some of the settings a
little bit later on but there's a lot of
things you can do to tweak vs code to
make it a perfect tool for you and then
this last one interactive playground
this is where if you're brand new this
is a good place to go and start this
will show you some of the things that
people don't use that often that we just
think are so great so this for example
multi cursor editing and this is a cool
playground because I can go in here and
actually just play with it right here so
if I want to do multi cursor I can do
that
it shows how to use intellisense which
we have here in BS code so I do dot or
control space and we can go up and down
and see the different methods for that
function or object can also do these
line actions so if I command I and then
this is just showing me if I do option
up and down we're all up and down I can
move that line so it's a good way to oh
how do I do things in vs code go to the
interactive playground and you can
quickly in two minutes see some of the
core features including rename
refactoring formatting code folding
errors and warnings here's a snippet so
we'll do a try-catch or even Emmet which
is a cool
you HTML expander so there we go about
about ten or so here that you can try
out in the interactive playground okay
so moving on to number three I showed
you the command palette briefly but this
was just so important I want to mention
it again not only can you see all of the
different commands but say you you
wanted to do this move line up and down
so you type that in in what's cool is
here on the far side so your guys is
right my right you can see the key
binding for that this is a great way to
start to memorize the key bindings you
can see oh I run this command a lot and
then start to remember the key binding
to get you faster and more productive as
some of you may know we have we built
this integrated terminal into vs code so
I type that into the command pal I'll do
that again so you can see it the command
palette type new integrated terminal it
shows up here and I can go up and down
here this is just a terminal like I
would have on the side it's built right
into the product and I can do a lot of
customizations here so if I open up
settings we'll make sure this is a
decent viewport
I can change things like my cursor style
I can change terminal integrated sex I
can change the different shell path that
I'm pointed to so you can really make
the integrated terminal be as good as
the terminal you're using outside of es
code which is a cool thing to bring
where you're doing your coding close to
the tools that you're running that being
said so I'll run this app that I built
we'll run it with this bash command
start
we'll let this load for a second so I
want to show you the next one here on my
tips and tricks is so I run this bash
start Sh this is just like my build
script right like I want to get up start
developing so I run this it launches a
server it launches my front-end
application and a really underused
feature is this thing called task runner
in vs cub so if I go any of the command
palette and I type configure task runner
if you're using javascript technologies
this will be familiar things like grunt
and gulp there's also MS build maven
dotnet core this is these are all
templates you can use to integrate via
Scott's task runner with your build
tools now you might be asking well
what's the difference between the task
runner and this integrated terminal you
just showed me well it actually allows
just for some simpler steps so you saw
down here I ran bash start Sh I can run
this task I'm gonna change the command
to bash in the arguments to start out Sh
so now I can run this task from the
command palette which is cool but not
that different than if I ran it from the
integrated terminal what I think is is
really useful though is if I now go to
the key to the key bindings file so this
is where you can customize your key
bindings and what I've done here on the
left is the default key bindings so this
is just a JSON file but this is how
things are listed today on the right are
the custom ones that I have added and
what I can do here is I can go and say
ok when I press f5 I want you to run
this task and we're giving it this
specific command I want it to run now
what I think is really cool about this
if you think about some things you like
in IDE land some things where you can
just click one button and things start
to happen you can make that happen right
here in vs code and it's all in JSON
files so it's easy to check in and share
with your team so if I go here I'm gonna
kill the application and now I'm going
to do run F but again around f5
and this will start the application just
with the keybinding press which is
pretty cool it basically makes this okay
I run my tools from the terminal all the
time
I can now integrate it with the task
runner and assign those two key bindings
to make things even faster let's see
here so this is just building okay so
this app here how many Star Trek fans do
we have okay a handful how many Star
Wars fans well it looks like the Star
Wars fans are winning out okay so this
is an arm-wrestling contest between Star
Wars and Star Trek okay Star Trek wins
that round what we're gonna do here next
is the show when we get in we're
actually writing some code so we're
gonna go here to app j/s and you'll
notice the little squigglies so this is
coming from vs Kota has some built-in
linting capabilities so this is things
like if you have some things wrong with
the syntax we're gonna mark that as an
error but you can also install these
extensions so I'm gonna show you some of
the extensions I have installed I have
this extension installed called es lint
so if you use JavaScript es lint is
familiar it's a really popular linting
tool and with es lint I can go in and
customize hey what errors and warnings
is vs code going to show me so I have
customized where es lint will mark if
I'm missing a semicolon as an error so
it's gonna mark this here I think you
guys can see that red squiggly there and
I can go in and fix this I can also see
where are the different errors and
warnings provided here by the es lint
you can imagine other linters can be
integrated in the same way and then I
can go and use the light bulb to fix
this so fix this semi problem and we'll
fix that there we can save it so BS code
has the flexibility to work with the
whole ecosystem of linters and that
gives you the customization here's my es
lint configuration file I'm saying hey
Marcus mi a 2 means an error
four es lint it allows you to really
customize hey what do we want to mark
stylistically as errors as warnings or
even things that are wrong that that we
want to enforce across our team's jump
here to where we're going with the demo
so that was number six number seven is
to really focus with Zen mode this is
one popular one request by the community
so I'm going to see how it looks there
okay so basically what it does it strips
out everything else you're focused you
you are in Zen mode you're just writing
some code so we're gonna go here to
franchise j/s and what I want to add is
I'm going to add let's keep track of how
many wins Star Trek has versus Star Wars
and this if you're not familiar this is
called a JSX it's syntactical sugar for
things like creating HTML elements so
we're going to do style equals and
you'll notice I get I get the
intellisense just like you would expect
when you're in some of these larger ide
so i'm getting this and we'll do winds
and let's make sure clothes that
so pretty cool so out-of-the-box you're
gonna get Intel sense for JavaScript and
typescript and then we'll toggle out of
Zen mode here so I can show you extent
then you can install other extensions
we'll go to show popular extensions for
other languages that you use so if you
use c-sharp install the c-sharp
extension Python C++ go PowerShell these
are all extensions that have lots and
lots of downloads you can see 2.1
million for the pythonic the python
extension but it brings the basic
capabilities like intellisense and
debugging that you don't get in a normal
text editor okay so let's let's verify
that that works so we'll do this again
Star Trek wins again and Star Trek wins
again so two wins there for Star Trek so
that worked for us but now I'm curious
why Star Trek's won every single time
I've ran this there's got to be
something wrong so we're gonna go here
this button right here is the debug icon
you're cancelling out the bugs what
we're going for really easy to set up
you go here and click this button here
and this creates your launch JSON file
you'll notice most of almost all our
configuration file are JSON files we
want it to make it easy to share easy to
check into version control we go here
this is by the way the other I said
there's two key bindings I think you
should remember the first one being to
open the command palette the second one
is control space when you're in the
editor this triggers intellisense so I
can see now a hint hey here's the
different configurations for this
debugging protocol so I want to do this
attach to process now this is a cool
debugging feature that I really like is
we go here make sure this is saved I'm
going to select attach to process and
I'm going to click Play and now it's
saying hey we detect there's three node
processes running so which one do you
want to attach to well I want to attach
to this one this is my server run
and you can see here I have the paws and
this thing means disconnect and now
where I want to go is server Jas and
we'll set a breakpoint there you can do
a couple different things with
breakpoints if you go in here you can
make them conditional so you can hit
them by the expression so some equality
expression or something like that or the
hit count I'm just going to use a normal
breakpoint
let's see if I can get out of that there
we go okay and now we're going to go
back over to our app and oh I I
disconnected the process there we go by
saving it there we go
I must add a stray one there now okay so
we hit the breakpoint so you can a
process is already running you attach to
the process you can set a breakpoint and
hit that process and try to understand
what's going on so we're trying to get
to the bottom of why the Star Trek win
every single time we can step in here
you can see everything you'd expect from
a normal debugging experience you can
hover over in this debug console we get
intellisense so we can print out and
explore objects and kind of see what's
going on and we're gonna step in here
and then we'll step into the function
okay so this is my my simple brain-dead
wrestle algorithm it's going to
calculate the Karma for the two
different franchises and it's going to
produce those and then we're gonna get
to which is our error here looks like
someone did X franchise equals Star Wars
return Y franchise so that looks like
the issue there here's something cool so
I installed this other extension called
annotator
and I can go in here and say let's see
if we can see who made that change it
was actually made by Star Wars is dumb
okay so we can go in here and see that
author so I'm gonna go in here and just
remove this guy we'll save it
and node Monell will restart the process
and let's go in here and see if Star
Wars can win Star Wars wins great so the
last tip here as we go in and we can do
use get really quickly and efficiently
you can see I click this version control
icon or source control I can see the
diff really easily so there's my
semicolon I added here's the paragraph
tag I added and here's the removal of
that faulty logic and we can just add
these files like this and write our
commit message restore order to the
galaxy and enter that commit and there
we go there's a whole bunch of options
pulling pushing you can do version
control is well supported not only get
but any of the other major version
control systems so that wraps it up here
I think that got me through all ten so
those are the top 10 most useful and
underused tips and tricks for vs code
again you can check out more at vs code
tips and tricks github repo check out
our product we're over at the booth over
by the developer tools and try it and
let us know what you think we're on
Twitter as well so thank you guys